[Music]
so what should we do for Halloween I was
thinking we could stay in have some wine
Alison's costume party costume party
yeah we can dress up and all my friends
will be there and none of yours well oh
I'm gonna start putting my costume hello
I'm Colonel Jack Brown of the United
States Air Force top-secret research and
development division if you're looking
for a way out of going to a costume
party this Halloween we may have the
answer it's not a Chewbacca costume it's
a cat piloted decoy Chewbacca you see
for decades we've been attempting to
perfect a back-mounted single-person
jetpack that would enable our soldiers
to achieve an unprecedented level of
maneuverability however the single pilot
air propulsion initiative resulted in
only one usable invention a robot that
looks like Chewbacca piloted by cats
each decoy true bakka is powered by a
miniature cold fusion reactor contains a
next-gen navigational computer utilizes
hyper advanced robotics and is piloted
by three semi-comatose trained cats why
cats because they're the only animal
apathetic enough to handle the neurosurg
of piloting a robot whereas other
animals who experience the robo neural
link panic and defecation cats just
don't care
each unit will be delivered to your
house in an inconspicuous package and
your assigned team of three cat pilots
will arrive separately posing as strays
the rest is up to you neroli any three
to decoy a Chewbacca now and their cat
control you look amazing let's go
[Music]
now you're free to spend the relaxing
evening at home while your cat piloted
decoy Chewbacca attends the costume
party in your place the decoy Chewbacca
can blend seamlessly into any social
situation from dancing to party
conversations oh my god so caddy donut
but instead a Chewbacca robot piloted by
cats
call now to rent your own cat piloted
decoy Chewbacca and yes your taxes paid
for this
[Applause]
[Music]